If you are a mother raising your daughters to be subservient to men,
you are the shittiest kind of mother on the planet.
And you don't deserve those children.
Your little girls should grow up having people who believe in them
for more than their baby making abilities.
You know in your fucking heart that you had different dreams,
that you had different fucking ideas of the world.
And somebody shove that shit down your throat.
And you know how fucking miserable it is to be subservient to some man
who makes you feel like shit every day?
Makes you feel like you're never enough.
You're never doing good enough.
You're never pretty enough,
skinny enough, talented enough.
Your food is never tasty enough.
Nothing you do is good enough to satisfy that man.
And you're gonna raise your fucking daughter
to do the same fucking thing?
Shame on you! The definition of misery loves company.
The fucking fucking definition of it.
It's disgusting! Shame on you,
shame on your husband. Shame on everything you fucking believe in.
And I hope your daughters desert you someday.